walking on walls spiderwebs that are
stronger than steel spider-man does not
have the market on this scientists are
making this a reality in the lab hi my
name is Aneesa Ramirez welcome to
science explained and to a special
edition on spider-man now in the 1960s
when Stan Lee created spider-man it was
all science fiction but now it is
science fact we're starting to learn how
to make spider webs in the lab and we
can also figure out how to walk on walls
so what exactly are spider webs spider
webs are made out of polymers polymers
are all over the place we have them in
backpacks seat belts carpets they're
actually in rubber bands as well
polymers are long-chain molecules you
can think of them as a plate of
spaghetti or a bunch of strings now when
you have a polymer it's very very strong
along the length there's strong bonds
within the polymer but there's weak
bonds between the polymers so they can
easily be broken
that's why spiderwebs are as strong as
steel pound-for-pound
in one direction but can easily be
broken in another direction so where can
we use these spiderweb materials well we
can use them to make bulletproof
clothing and also parachutes spider webs
really Rock now what else can we learn
from spider-man I don't know how about
to walk on walls spiders walk on walls
how do they do this they do this with
Van der Waals force you see at the
bottom of their feet are small hairs
that attract the molecules of the wall
more surface more opportunities for that
attraction to occur geckos do the same
thing so you see spiders are not scary
they're our friends and by learning what
they do we can be superhuman but we have
to follow the advice of Stanley with
great power comes great responsibility
I'm Aneesa Ramirez thanks for joining me
at science explained and I hope that
you'll come back for another edition